in the war in ukraine the situation is
turning dire in a critical city in the
east of the country troops defending the
area have lost more ground to russian
troops in intense fighting one official
in the region says the city could soon
be cut off with no way to evacuate
civilians chris lipsey reports on
ukraine's desperate effort in a battle
that could decide the war
the last bridge to severo donetsk
destroyed now for one hundred thousand
ukrainians there's no way out
you have two options say the pro-russian
separatists surrender or die
the ukrainian army is high on tenacity
but low on ammo
to make sure none is wasted they launch
these american surveillance drones to
help the gunners with coordinates for
attack
they can't afford to miss says major
alexander we have to get closer and take
more risks because our enemies have
long-range artillery
long-range artillery like this russian
groud rocket launcher destroyed by
ukrainians using american howitzers
if only they had more of them says joe
goddard a former british soldier now
training ukraine's national guard well
that is the sad part i mean these guys
want to go and fight they want to take
villages they want to actually push the
russians back but the problem is the the
sheer
unevenness of uh
well the equipment they've got so
they're being smashed every day in the
trenches with these heavy guns
and uh they want to do more but they
can't ukraine is now asking for an
additional 1 000 howitzers 500 tanks and
1 000 drones among other heavy weapons
without them the city of severo donetsk
that crucial domino in the don boss
risks falling any day for cbs morning's
chris livesay dinipro ukraine